or just trying to build little bits of
the puzzle what do you remember about
the incident I like this one look at the
map what were you when it happened I
don't remember when you came around
did you see people yes
what were they doing
they were dead we are an awful I like
Theo
oh we both went through the sooner we
get back to a normal routine the better
[Music]
Oh Bart and Blackwell said he sent me
exactly where I needed to be into who I
needed to be with his sure mother dead
too
yes
I knew you were there and I know what
else was in that room
the goldfish before and after everything
is before and after in the middle is the
painting
that's life
Beefalo miracle after miracle it
survived
there's something important I have to
tell you
until you
is it lost
[Music]
even the tiniest things mean something
[Applause]
who took the pain
[Music]
Rockets forever
maybe sometimes go to the can come from
bed
[Music]
who's my thought she died
[Music]
I would have given it back I swear
[Music]
you